AINSLEY, SEND IT TO YOU.
AINSLEY: THANK YOU SO MUCH,
JILLIAN.
CRISIS SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL
WITH A RECORD NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS EVERY SINGLE MONTH.
THOUGHT BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
REPORTEDLY WEIGHING REINSTATING
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP’S REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY.
HERE NOW TO REACT IS RETIRED
ACTING ICE DIRECTOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR MR. TOM HOMAN, GOOD
MORNING TO YOU, TOM IN.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: WHY DO YOU THINK
THEY’RE WEIGHING THIS LIGHT
VERSION OF THIS REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY THAT TRUMP HAS STATED?
WHY ARE THEY INTERESTED IN THAT
NOW?
IS IT BECAUSE THE POLL NUMBERS
ARE BAD?
>> WELL, THAT’S THE BIGGEST
REASON.
LOOK, THIS PAST MONTH IS GOING
TO BE OVER 200,000 AGAIN.
THEY HAVEN’T ANNOUNCED IT YET
BUT IT’S OVER 200,000.
THEY HAVEN’T ANNOUNCED IT BUT
TRYING TO FIGURE A WAY TO SPIN
IT.
THEY CAN’T SURVIVE THIS THEY
CAN’T TAKE THIS BEATING EVERY
MONTH.
I’M SURE THERE IS PEOPLE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT ARE NOT AN
IDIOT THAT REALIZE THAT, LOOK,
THIS IS GOING TO HURT YOU WAS IN
THE MIDTERMS.
SO UNDERSTAND THIS FIRST OF ALL,
THEY ARE GOING TO REINSTATE
REMAIN IN MEXICO PROGRAM AT
LEAST THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
BECAUSE THEY WERE ORDERED BY THE
COURT SYSTEM.
I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THREE
LAWSUITS.
I WROTE MORE AFFIDAVITS SUING
THIS PRESIDENT THAN DID I MY
ENTIRE CAREER.
WE WON THE MORATORIUM ON
DEPORTATIONS AND WON THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO PROGRAM.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE TO BE ORDERED
BY THE COURTS DO THEIR JOB.
WHAT’S THE FIRST THING THEY
DEAL?
THEY APPEAL THEIR DECISION
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO CONTINUE
DOING WHAT THEY’RE DOING.
I’M CONVINCED PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE SAYING LOOK, THIS IS
BAD, THIS ISN’T WORKING.
WE ARE GOING TO LOSE THE
MIDTERMS AND PROBABLY THE WHITE
HOUSE IF WE DON’T CHANGE
POLICIES AND CONTROL THE BORDER.
AINSLEY: THERE WAS A GUY ON FOX
SEVERAL TIMES BRENT SMITH A
RANCHNER KENNY, TEXAS, HE SAID
HE HAS HAD TO SPEND $60,000 TO
REPAIR THE FENCES ON HIS
PROPERTY.
HE SAID HE HAS FOUND THREE
BODIES IN THE AREA LAST WEEK.
HE SAYS IF YOU DON’T HAVE A GUN
YOU ARE GOING OUT ON YOUR OWN
RISK OWE SAYS WE CAN’T WALK IN
OUR BACKYARDS EVEN DURING THE
DAYLIGHT.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE STORIES YOU
HEARD DOWN THERE?
>> I WALKED TO ONE SHERIFF LAST
MONTH FOUND 48 TODAY MIGRANTS IN
HIS COUNTY ALONE.
48.
ONE COUNTY OUT OF HUNDREDS OF
COUNTIES ON THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER.
THE THING I HEAR THE MOST IS IT
ABOUT RIGHT NOW IT’S MISSING
FAMILIES, RIGHT?
OVER 112,000 CHILDREN HAVE
ENTERED THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY,
WHICH IS THE HIGHEST NUMBER IN
THE HISTORY OF THE BORDER PATROL
CAME OUT LAST WEEK ABOUT 40% OF
FAMILY UNIT CAN’T BE FOUND.
NOW THEY ATTACKED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FOR 2500 FAMILY
SEPARATIONS BUT IN THE MEANTIME
THEY HAVE 45,000 CHILDREN THEY
CAN’T FIND THIS IS INHUMANE
POLICY.
HAD CHILDREN ARE DYING.
RECORD AMOUNT OF FENTANYL IN
THIS COUNTRY CAUSED OVER 90,000
OVERDOSE DEATH.
THEY ARE NOT DOING A THING ABOUT
IT THEY HAD TO BE ORDERED BY THE
COURT TO DO ANYWHERE JOB AND
SECURE THE BORDER THEY ARE NOT
DOING IT TO SECURE THE BORDER.
ONLY REASON INTERESTED IN
CHANGING SOME OF THESE POLICIES
AT ALL?
AINSLEY: THEY WANT TEXAS AND ARI
AND SOME OF HERE TO OTHER STATES
TO TURN BLUE.
>> THEY ARE AFRAID THEY WILL
LOSE THE MIDTERMS BECAUSE OF THE
BORDER CRISIS.
THIS IS ABOUT POLITICS.
THIS ISN’T ABOUT DOING THE RIGHT
THING FOR THIS COUNTRY.
LOOKING TO GET BACK TO SOME OF
THE TRUMP POLICIES BECAUSE OF
THE ELECTION.
ABOUT THEIR POLITICAL FUTURE.
NOT THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
OUR COUNTRY.
AINSLEY: YEAH.
THEN YOU HAVE THE AFGHANISTAN
PROBLEM.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS?
>> LET’S NOT LEAVE AFGHANISTAN
PROBLEM.
THE BORDER IS NOW VULNERABLE
THAN IT’S EVER OPINION.
WE ALREADY KNOW BORDER PATROL.
THAT’S WHY THE FENTANYL IS
COMING ACROSS.
1. MILLION ENCOUNTERS ALREADY ON
THE BORDER.
THOUSANDS OF TERRORISTS HAVE
BEEN RELEASED FROM THE PRISONS
IN AFGHANISTAN WHOSE SOLE
PURPOSE IN LIFE IS TO DO HARM TO
THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOU ARE A TERRORIST AND WANT
TO DO HARM TO COUNTRY CAN’T GET
A PLANE TICKET VISA BECAUSE OF
THE CHECKS OF 9/11.
COME ACROSS THE SOUTHWEST BORDER
THE SAME WAY 20 MILLION OTHERS
DID.
AINSLEY: VERY SCARY.
I READ A STORY THIS MORNING THAT
THOUSANDS OF THEM HAVE BEEN
DEEMED AT RISK THE ONES THAT WE